as fotos que vão aparecer é são todas
minhas eu gosto de fotografar casas
antigas e paisagens e vocês vocês
conhecem alguém que faz coleção de
coisas antigas ou então que já contou
pra vocês como era a vida antigamente e
na cidade de vocês
qual é o lugar que traz boas recordações
para vocês e vocês sabem depois de tanto
tempo como está esse lugar
será que ele ainda existe será que foi
transformado o ele ficou desgastado pelo
tempo
eu morei nessa casa aí
essa é a casa que é a minha boa
lembrança e vocês é podem perceber que
às vezes a gente recebe nas redes
sociais algumas fotos coisas antigas
coisas da infância pedido se você lembra
disso curta compartilhe e nós acabamos
curtindo compartilhando porquê porque é
uma memória nossa é significativo para
nós e nós vamos ver que a nossa cidade
ela também tem uma memória
ela tem um patrimônio cultural o nosso
está também o nosso país também e o
mundo porque todos nós já ouvimos essa
expressão patrimônio cultural da
humanidade e o fundamento da preservação
é o nosso direito à memória individual
coletiva e também a nossa identidade
cultural
essa foto é do bairro rio da luz em
jaraguá do sul que fica próximo à
blumenau
esse é um bairro tipicamente germânica
da época dos imigrantes
quando eu estava lá um amigo me
perguntou se aquele você sabia que o
bairro todo foi tombado pelo patrimônio
histórico
eu tive uma curiosidade jurídica na
verdade saber como é que isso se deu
como que seria administrado ea partir
daí eu fui pesquisar e essa minha
pesquisa me me aproximou do tema da
paisagem cultural e que me leva a uma
revisão de de vários conceitos da área e
uma nova jornada na verdade conhecimento
pra mim é e nós temos que levar em conta
na questão da preservação que para a
preservação efetiva nós temos que ter
três passos
o primeiro é conhecer o segundo é
utilizar
e o terceiro é colaborar no primeiro
passo nós temos que ver que ninguém
preserva que não conhece
então nós temos que divulgar quais são
os bens e as leis básicas incentivos e
como funciona o sistema de preservação
porque porque só assim a comunidade nós
próprios podemos ter uma base para
propor novas soluções novas intervenções
novos usos do património no segundo
passo é utilizar na verdade é preservar
para usar porque os bens do patrimônio
bem preservados eles não estão numa
redoma afastados do nosso cotidiano e
eles estão aí para serem usufruídos pela
comunidade e nós vamos ver que no
estatuto da cidade já está previsto que
a preservação é uma diretriz da política
urbana para o pleno desenvolvimento das
funções sociais da sociedade da cidade e
da propriedade
o terceiro passo é o colar eu colaborar
na colaboração
atualmente a internet eu acredito que
facilita muito a questão da colaboração
ea colaboração já nasci lá com a
constituição federal de 88 o nosso
modelo preservacionista ele é
colaborativa
o poder público faz essa preservação com
a colaboração da comunidade
os bebês que vamos preservar nós podemos
classificar em bens materiais e bens
imateriais
os materiais são os imóveis as coisas
objetos
os monumentos eles são tão baixos
já os bens materiais
eles são as manifestações culturais da
comunidade expressões artísticas
são festas cerimônias são saberes locais
são é modos de produção modos de fazer
as coisas
nós vamos ver um panorama da preservação
que quando o ser humano ele se
estabelece qualquer lugar
ele tem a sua vida ali
dividida em três atores principais
primeiro ele vai construir depois ele
vai conviver e ele vai criar também
naquele local
e aqui eu vou dar alguns exemplos
lá da cidade onde eu moro agora que é
são josé ao lado de florianópolis
ali é uma cidade é tipicamente de
colonização açoriana que iniciou em 1750
não vou dar alguns exemplos no segmento
ali de construção existe um centro
histórico um casario uma igreja em torno
de uma praia
então existe uma lei municipal que
instituiu o projeto conhecer são josé
nele as escolas e os grupos interessados
agendando visitas com um monitor um
historiador por todo o circuito deste
centro histórico é para a divulgação no
segmento da convivência foi feito o
registro da festa do divino é uma festa
religiosa tradicional foi feito seu
registro para incentivar a continuidade
da festa e também existe a feira da
freguesia um domingo por mês quando a
população é convidada a usar a praça
numa feira com artesãos com grupos
artísticos né locais neste domingo ficam
abertos os casarões da biblioteca
casarão da casa da cultura e do museu no
terceiro segmento ali criar se entendeu
rede é registrar como também património
imaterial ofício de roller
acontece que a produção de utensílios de
barro foi muito importante na economia
do município até meados do século
passado então para não se perder essa
tradição e se saber fazer
existem as escolas de goleiro e 11 uma
série de incentivos não é para continuar
e se esse saber ea paisagem cultural
na verdade a paisagem cultural ela é um
conceito bastante recente desenvolvido
pela unesco a partir dos anos 70 na
nossa legislação aparece em 2009 não a
portaria do iphan que fez os primeiros
estudos na verdade
ela é um cenário quando se chega à
conclusão que para manter um determinado
local
não basta apenas um tombamento de um bem
do prédio o registro de uma festa é
preciso muito mais é preciso muito
esforço coordenado muitas ações para
gerar renda para preservar pra educar as
pessoas
então se faz a paisagem cultural
chancela da paisagem cultural
nada mais é do que o poder público
colocar um selo de qualidade naquela
determinada a paisagem é dizendo que
pretende fazer todos os esforços para
preservá lo e como é que vai se dar isso
primeiro existe um estudo do iphan nos
locais
depois um decreto e depois um termo de
cooperação entre estado e municípios
aí a união é por exemplo se quiséssemos
é preservar locais onde ainda existem
bem presentes esses modos de construir é
de criar de conviver dos imigrantes que
chegaram como se faria isso seria feito
estudo por exemplo o projeto rota da
imigração neste projeto foi feito este
estudo foi feito este termo e este termo
ele foi feito com a assinatura de 16
municípios onde foram tombados 50 é e
nove imóveis e também dois núcleos
históricos
e acontece que estes projectos de
paisagem cultural na verdade é um
assunto bastante recente que ele pode se
ligar a vários temas
ele é bem multidisciplinar está dando os
primeiros passos e tem que não vai ser
divulgado será aberto novas novas portas
novas frentes de tudo esse aqui apenas
algumas linhas na verdade pra vocês
porque o importante é você saber que na
cidade de vocês vocês podem escolher
alguma paisagem e considera importantes
algum bem que considera importante
preservar e fazer os projetos ou
articular a idéia de vocês com outros
projetos porque o importante é a
presença relação para a usufrui são da
comunidade porque é um tema ligado à
cidadania ao turismo e ao
desenvolvimento econômico a uma geração
de renda
eu há uns tempos atrás eu fui ali em são
josé
justamente conhecer esse trabalho dos
goleiros
essa legislação o que eles estavam
fazendo
então eu fui até a escola de oleiros e
ali eu encomendei um vaso vazio pra mim
eles fazem encomendas eles fazem pra
ainda ainda comercializam esses produtos
e eu plantei sementes no meu faço e teve
fazia isso novas idéias e hoje aqui eu
convido vocês para que vocês também
tenham novas idéias novas ligações das
idéias de vocês com este tema e plantas
suas idéias e meia as ideias porque o
patrimônio cultural da cidade é de todos
nós